[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
racism and xenophobia are unfortunately
everywhere however one woman is turning
this
into this
meet germany's hate destroyer
[Music]
in germany former teacher emelia mensa
schram has made it her life mission to
remove any neo-nazi stickers and
graffiti around her country
it's no easy feat though nein
and how does one arm oneself for a war
against street hate with them cancer
chavo or the nagalaki fan order even
with fabs
irmela has been covering removing and
obscuring these messages since the 80s
she keeps a record of everything she's
wiped out all
over her country
[Applause]
thousands
every day except for sundays omela packs
her bags and heads off to the streets
sometimes she nails a big one like this
heart
it used to be a swastika other times
it's small but even the crudest message
doesn't slip by
[Music]
my
side
the sphere
from their native again
[Music]
and as long as there's hate in this
world omela will be there
can in hand
how is the comment
[Music]
good
[Music]
when i realized that monuments of those
who served our country and fought for
the freedoms that we enjoy today were in
disrepair and poor condition
it upset me
it's sad to see that they've been
forgotten completely most of them are
unreadable so no one can tell who they
are
what they did and how they served our
country and what they meant to our
country
if you find a gleaming stone that may be
100 or 150 years old there's a good
chance that i've probably been there
[Music]
my name is andrew lumischer better known
as the good cemeterian i restore the
monuments of veterans who served in
multiple conflicts for our country and
their families
i complete restorations on my day off
typically which is sunday i restored
between five and six hundred monuments
to date
[Music]
living in the south there is a multitude
of things that accumulate on a given
stone
it may have more than 100 years of build
up and mildew and mold it's very tedious
it's very hard work soaking a stone with
water scrubbing with brushes there are
toothbrushes and q-tips
a monument restoration typically will
take between two and four months but
there's nothing that makes me feel as
good as when i complete a restoration
the reason i began doing this is for
both personal and historical reasons
i have friends who served friends who i
lost
both in battle and combat and friends
who lost their battle once they came
back home
it's important to me
to see
that they can be remembered and not
forgotten
the monuments themselves
are not just stones you know i want to
uncover who they were as a human being
as a person uh in addition to their
sacrifice and their service to our
country
because they weren't just soldiers
either they were americans first they
were soldiers second
i can't
allow that to be forgotten
fancy going shopping
[Music]
stop
no no no no whistling in the bulletin
arcade uh who are you we are the
burlington beatles
probably the oldest and smallest police
force in the world you could say that we
police your manners
right
okay
well mark lord head beedle of the
burlington arcade tell us your story the
beatles story started before we get into
that what actually is a beadle to be
honest with you i don't think anybody
really knows
we pre-date any police force in the
country right back to the story go ahead
mark the beatles story started at this
arcade arcade are there games here no
so
it's just like a shopping center right
yes
okay third time lucky go ahead mark the
beatles story started on the 20th of
march 1819. london was very different
people didn't really adjust to water so
they drank either gin or beer and
obviously that leads to a certain type
of behaviour so the beagle's role really
was to keep order within the arcade and
in fact that tradition is carried on
right away through to today
our uniforms
are made up of several different layers
we first of all put on our wastegates
then our frock coats and our top hats in
the summer or the autumn in the winter
you will still put on your waistcoats
you will then put on your cape and your
top hat
the original rules here were no
whistling because the pig pockets would
whistle signals to one another no
drunkenness play a musical instrument
you're not supposed to hurry some
gentleman like a run ladylike carry your
own parcels you mustn't bring a bicycle
and accompanied ladies by the way won't
also allow them now lots of those rules
we couldn't enforce today
[Music]
we still try to enforce the no hurrying
we still try to enforce no whistling
it's all about behaviour as long as
you're respecting those around you and
respecting the arcade you'll be left
alone
and i put this uniform on i represent
nearly 200 years worth of history it
makes me immensely proud yeah i want to
stay here till i retire
if i'm honest with you that's absolutely
true by the way that isn't just the uh
you know the spill
[Music]
there's so many reasons why i do what i
do
i love surfing and i love helping people
i think if everybody found what they
loved to do what they were designed to
do and use that gift to help others this
world would look so different
my name is lambert lowe and i'm a surf
instructor
i was living in hawaii living the dream
teaching surfing to billionaires and
celebrities
at the end of the day something was
missing and i knew in my heart that i
needed to come back to where it all
started
i grew up in california the ocean was
where i felt the most connected
i came back and started a non-profit
called the mix academy
[Music]
one of the things that come out of the
mix academy is this surf school
and i brought that gift of surfing here
with some of the people that need the
most smiles push up from the side stand
up go my current class consists of a
refugee from north korea
nathan a nine-year-old who's visually
impaired and shannon a veteran going
through alcoholism
[Music]
school of the misfits is a place where
you can belong on land everyone looks at
us a little differently but when you're
in the water the water washes all that
off
surfing like life is full of ups and
downs there's waves that are coming
and you can't stop that from coming pain
is going to come what you can't control
is yourself and how you're going to
react
you can choose to paddle for it embrace
it adapt to it and enjoy the ride or
this wave is going to come and it's
going to knock you out and it's going to
wipe you out
catching a wave is a great feeling
helping others catch their first wave is
a greater feeling
to watch that smile just ear to ear and
knowing that man that's gonna change
someone's life
[Music]
you